SHANEE NISHRY: Hey, I
did not see you there.
I was just watching 360
videos with Cardboard.
HUSAIN BENGALI: Did you mean
you were watching a Jump video?
SHANEE NISHRY:
Yes, that's right.
HUSAIN BENGALI: That's great.
Have you checked
out the Jump camera?
SHANEE NISHRY: Let's go see it.
HUSAIN BENGALI: Great.
Let's do it.
So here we have our
Jump camera, which
is 16 camera modules in
a circular arrangement.
And this allows us to capture
stereoscopic 360 video
in a way better
than ever before.
What we do with
these 16 cameras is
we take the video
coming from them
and put it in our
cloud assembler.
Our assembler uses thousands
of machines and some software
magic to create a
seamless panorama.
That's a panorama without
any boundaries, borders.
And you get to take a
look at this in 360 3D,
which means near things look
near, far things look far.
And you can look anywhere
just like you normally
would if you were
actually in a place.
SHANEE NISHRY: And we are using
Cardboard to look at it as
though a video's through it.
And speaking of Cardboard,
we have a new version here.
We have replaced the magnet
with a capacitive trigger
right here.
And now it gives us the
access to a lot more devices,
such as iOS iPhone devices.
And speaking of
Jump and Cardboard,
what else can we do with it?
HUSAIN BENGALI: With Jump,
that's a great question.
So I think we're only at
the tip of the iceberg
as far as possibilities
with Jump go.
We hope you will use Jump
to capture some of the most
beautiful places on Earth.
In fact, Expeditions, which
is a way for school children
to go on field trips while
sitting in their classrooms,
through the help of VR,
is using some Jump content
to go to really interesting
and educational places.
SHANEE NISHRY: That's awesome.
You know what I'd like?
I'd love if a class could be
studying Mars, for example,
using 360 videos.
HUSAIN BENGALI: Yeah,
we need to figure out
how to get this thing to Mars.
SHANEE NISHRY: But if
you're a developer,
then check out our website.
We have listed a new UX
library, a new UX application,
so you can see our best
practices for designing for VR.
Thank you for
watching us from I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]